let me pull up this story this one's
funny we got it from business insider
biden used the term ultra maga
after six months of research now
republicans have put it on t-shirts
they can't meme
that's like so during 2015 and 16 there
was a subreddit called the left can't
meme and it i mean it's just reality the
left could not meme so they banned all
of the big pop prominent you know meme
channels instagram had a huge purge
and then along popped up these really
generic
left-wing meme channels and it was just
so obvious that it's astroturfed this is
what happens when they try ultra maga
and now they're selling t-shirts with it
because it's hilarious here's my
favorite biden calls trump the great
manga king
why did he think anyone would be upset
about that that's amazing yeah i put
that on my on my twitter as my twitter
name the great magic king yeah
joe biden is you know he's leading a
rally where he's trying to get people to
hate the right and he goes these these
right-wingers these really cool awesome
nice people everywhere they're just like
the coolest guys ever and and i think
they shouldn't be in office but they're
really smart and great those ultra mega
that maggot keg is like everything that
the light touches we're gonna build a
wall around it okay building a wall
around everything the hyenas are not
sending their best okay when it comes to
a culture war if you want to call it
this thing culture war you can't if you
use your opponent's language you've lost
so that's what biden just did i think i
think you're right in many ways so what
the conservatives have been doing for
years which has been extremely painful
is they've been trying to use left-wing
terminology against the left and they've
been trying to exceed territory to them
so they'll say things like the left are
the real homophobes for example
now groomer that we have been using the
term groomer which is effective and
accurate
and the left has been starting to say no
actually the right of the real groomers
and i'm going you've lost there's
already been several blogs where they
say actually grooming is a good thing
some of them yeah some of them are
saying it's a good thing some of them
are saying the right are the real
groomers so they're but they're
basically accepting the narrative
regardless i saw james lindsay posted
this i think it was james lindsay he was
like as soon as you get the term they
try and take it from you and now they're
like if you mean grooming my child to be
a good person and loving and accepting
then i stand guilty as charged and it's
like okay you're a groomer
okay groomer like getting them to use
this language is is doing two things in
some instances such as the ones you've
mentioned they're showing their true
hand they're saying oh actually it's a
good thing we are in favor of it in
another instance they're denying it but
by denying it they are reinforcing
culturally that it is in fact a bad
thing
and for so long
the right has been doing that with the
left terminology oh i'm not homophobic
oh i'm not transphobic the left are the
real transphobes but the left are the
real racists that's true
i think well when you look at like the
early progressive movement yeah
absolutely i i mean even until this day
yeah but when you look at the
ideological roots of the progressive
movement yes absolutely i don't think it
goes all the way back we've talked about
breaking down
are there people associated with the
right whatever that means who are racist
yes in fact there are many are they the
majority no
do they have a lot of power in the
government not really when that one guy
was a steve king
said what's wrong with white nationalism
they booted off all assignments and then
he got he got primary and he's gone now
on the left
are they racist yes they they overtly
advocate for racial segregation in
california they tried to repeal their
civil rights provision from their
constitution they tried to repeal the
non-discrimination provision from their
own constitution it's like dude that is
that is the rule not the exception on
the right it's the exception not the
rule and i think the uh the main reason
is that
moderate individuals two to one move
have aligned more with republicans
simply you look at elon musk's meme
because the left has gone off the rails
so we all stay in the same place
traditional liberals but it's like if i
got to choose between those crazy people
who want to kill babies in nine months
and those guys who are like hey don't
kill babies i'm gonna go with the hey
don't kill babies
absolutely and you know i i'd actually
be curious to see if someone could do
some sort of detailed statistical
analysis on exactly how many maniacs
there really are within our society who
would say something like children should
transition their gender i mean if the
progressive left according to pew
research is only six percent of the
general public and even those people as
they've defined progressive left don't
really perfectly fit in with that
category how many people actually
believe in something like yeah but why
trans you know transitioning children
giving sex changes to children pushing
them along to that process uh and we
also see this is something that is being
paired by even the president of the
united states and to your point the
reason people are following along with
it is because in many cases they're
cowardly there are a lot of people who
won't stand up and say that's a
disgusting horrible thing to do
uh because they're afraid of the social
ramifications oh and it's also they're
they're the people that are around would
lambast them if they did it i noticed
with me and you will have talks about
religion and catholicism you know i'm
pretty critical but if we have other
catholic guests on and i say that
everyone comes at me and it's like
almost like i feel bad like as a human
like my i get stressed and like my
genetics are like oh you're not gonna be
as healthy now because of this stress so
like there's an incentive not to speak
out against a group
i noticed uh when i was 13 or 12 or 13
this uh what do they call it um
affirmative action and i realized i was
like 13 1992. wait you mean if i do
better than a guy who's black
for a job interview they'll give it to
him because they need to fill a quota
that's reverse racism and then as i got
older i realized oh that's just racism
yes but then i started to think about
class issues and and it's a whole other
nuanced conversation in there but man
did it feel bad
to hear that i i wouldn't get the job
because of my skin color yeah whenever
i'm applying for jobs i get to click a
whole bunch of like little you know tech
marks i'm a woman i'm an immigrant um
latin american i'm this and that i'm
like i i got pretty good chances to get
this job now because i'll look at how
many boxes i clicked i like how these
the leftists are like everybody line up
according to the color of your skin and
the size of your boobs yeah it's like
that's creepy dude
i wanted to bring up real quick there is
a
a tweet that went viral from this
account called jack califano and it said
the groomer and pedophile thing are the
clearest moment where i've thought oh
wow they're really planning on killing a
lot of people eventually so they're like
make the the left is saying that if you
if you're pushing the groomer and
pedophile thing is because you're trying
to and so this tweet has 61.2
likes as a as of this 71.2
okay thousand thousand sorry this is
extreme dehumanizing language designed
to prepare the right wing fascists to
feel no remorse over genocidal acts of
violence
um
they live in that world and
the issue is what
what do you think happens
when you actually have these people
who are going into little girls
bathrooms and taking pictures of them
and then
like
we're going to come to the point where
someone's going to punch something you
can't say nothing about it you can't
call them groomers because now you're a
genocidal
maniac that wants like it it has nothing
to do with tactics it has nothing it
doesn't matter
like we talked about that video game guy
from the washington post who's like you
know i hope they use this picture of me
they literally don't care what any of us
think
they're saying this for themselves
doesn't matter and they don't want your
apology either no there's nothing you
can say to them that's why that's why
you know uh
they
there's a tendency for the left not to
interact with the right in any way they
don't care what you think they're lying
they're not interested in telling the
truth and if you go to them and say i'd
like to correct the record they say shut
up so going back to what you were saying
before ian where you're like they say
that we're lying in you know the left
and the right
when when when uh prominent left-wing
personalities take clips from this show
out of context
and then put them up like they did to
you i think media matters did that they
didn't take when you were talking about
the n-word they didn't take the full
context into what you were saying they
just try to make it seem like you were
racist
when you go to them and say hey i'd like
to show you what actually happened they
say we don't care we don't they don't
care they're not going to correct it
they'll on on twitter they'll put up a
fake story they love it they just don't
care they're you know what i think it is
children they're immature they did not
they did not reach adulthood millennials
are a stunted narcissistic generation
certainly there are many millennials
more so like you know i don't know are
you a millennial how old are you um
undisclosed we're going to the break now
yeah when this millennial began what
year i don't know it's like 82 or
something is that yeah yeah i'm 94 so
okay i'm still millennial yeah yeah yeah
but i identify as gen z yeah there you
go so so they're i mean there are
millennials who are like responsible
adults of course i'm not saying every
single millennial but what we see i
think with the left is
why are they so cult-like and
zombie-like because they never grew up
they never have they have no strong mind
for for living and being responsible for
themselves
i noticed about i would like to see the
numbers of how wealthy people are if you
want to break you guys know i'm not into
breaking people into categories for the
most part but i will for the sake of
communication the left and the right how
wealthy are the people on the left
relative to the people on the right
because i tend to find that more richer
the wealthier people get except for the
ones at the very top manipulating the
game the more wealthy that an individual
gets the more conservative they get
because they're happy with the status
quo but if you don't have money you
start to freak out and become
revolutionary
i'm not sure i mean i think that at this
point and i couldn't speak to any
specific statistic here other than one
which doesn't perfectly map on but
basically that you're more likely to
support uh intervening on behalf of
ukraine if you have a higher net worth
or make more money uh something along
those lines but no my point is i think
that the the progressive especially when
you're dealing with like the like real
progressive left we're talking to people
with all the bizarre theories about
gender i would venture to guess that
they are much wealthier as a group you
you don't meet working-class people who
believe that kind of stuff it started in
2012 the democrats overtook the
republicans as the party of the uh top
four percent of income earners
i i can only assume it's increased since
then but isn't it isn't it isn't it
interesting that's like this
the switch when things started getting
weird things started changing occupy
wall street and then all of a sudden you
have post liberals now voting with
republicans why well the republicans
were like we're going to bring jobs back
to the midwest into michigan and the
democrats were like free trade with
china
what's that saying that i i i forgot who
says that uh
but a conservative is a liberal who's
been mugged by reality
so it's like
they live in their own little world and
that's one of the biggest things that i
i try to you know talk in relation to my
activism in my commentary is that
there's a lot of like
bad bad situation that will come from
those policies i mean we've seen it
we're seeing it we're seeing it now and
we're gonna see more and more of that
and
i feel like a lot of this is sort of
like comes from a place of
you're spoiled you don't know what those
policies are actually gonna bring to
america how they're actually gonna pan
out i'm telling you it's not gonna turn
out that way and if you do keep going
down this road you're gonna get wrecked
i don't want you to get erect
let's not do that let's not do this to
the country
and then they're like oh but but it's
going to be different we're going to
wait until like like with socialism
they think that if the government
amasses all this power and all this
money then it's going to be different
this time they're gonna have a better
guy they're gonna have a nicer guy okay
but if you're gonna still have democracy
then later four years from now what if a
bad guy comes in and uses all that money
and all that power to his own evil
intents like you don't think about the
consequences
of all these policies that you're
pushing and how uh
how badly they can affect other people
because you're not gonna be the first
ones to be affected by that like you
you're not the people who are living
you know people in texas they're living
by the border they're seeing all of that
they're seeing the violence in the
communities they're seeing the human
trafficking you're not going to be
affected by that because you're you live
in new york uh you're not the woman
that's being human trafficked you're not
the woman that's being used as a mew so
it's it's easy for you to push these
policies when you're not affected by it
directly so i feel like it sort of like
comes from a place of wealth and a place
of
entitlement because
as they go through reality and they
actually they get bugged by reality they
tend to become a little bit more
conservative but
um
there is an extent of
how things can
really really get bad
and i i don't wish that upon america i
wish we would wake up
before that
but i i i i don't know if it will you
were speaking from experience you came
from brazil you said at the beginning of
the show what did you what kind of
things did you see there that
made you so sensitive to it so um
i mean everything everything that
um you think about for example you talk
about health care but it's it's sort of
like all of it is in theory but it's not
really it doesn't consider the practice
of like let's say human corruption or
all the other different things that
could add like liking in theory
everything is perfect of course but
let's say you amass all this power all
this money you take it away from me the
individual and you give it to the
government and then what if somebody
comes into the government who's not a
good person like you're not considering
that you're not considering the
corruption you're not considering the
waste you're not considering all these
different things so
um
violence uh corruption
even when they say free health care like
uh yeah i have free health care uh i
didn't like it i mean i didn't like it
it's i had to
stand up around the block on the queue
that by the time you're you get to the
door of the hospital it's you're you're
dead so it's like
it's it's sort of like
there is another option there is another
way it's not just
completely not have health care or have
government-sponsored healthcare because
you're gonna have
so much corruption like imagine how what
we're seeing right now with pfizer and
all of that like if you charge me you
guys tell me to shut up if i'm talking
too much but like
if you if i go to the hospital
and you tell me i have to pay 300
i'm okay i'm looking at the receipt
because i work for those 300 so i want
to make sure what i'm paying
now if that bill never touches my hand
it goes directly to the government the
insurance is building it or the
companies are billing it directly to the
government the government is not going
to look at all of that one by one it's
going to inflate the prices it's going
to create a huge mess in the system a
huge corrupt mess in the system so
why can't instead of
doing that why can't we consider
affordable health care because health
care is not affordable right now we have
these companies uh lobbying in bed with
the government that's the actual
definition of fascism but
we're not ready for that conversation we
want to be polarized so thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you